cette histoire de sorcellerie au sein
des marseillais devenu un véritable
feuilleton que les françaises suivent
désormais chaque soir cette affaire de
sorcellerie
tout le monde en parle depuis deux
semaines les protagonistes au coeur de
cette affaire se sont succédé sur notre
plateau d'abord magali berda agents de
carla carla dit depuis samedi matin
qu'elle l'a fait sous influence et elle
ne nie pas ses notes audio vous est donc
ya pas de montage depuis karl amoureux
elle même temps que ceux formulés par ce
genre de chasse ouais c'est pas partir
dana et la voyante était venu donner son
droit de réponse
on venait me demander des prestations
c'est elle qui venait me demander
je peux tout justifié d'hier soir c'est
ward a eu notre voyante en relation avec
danahy qui a lâché une bombe
elle remettra en cause le rôle de magali
berda dans cette affaire apparemment au
courant depuis le début alors magali
berda at elle volontairement fait chuter
le scandale ce soir elle est avec nous
pour nous apporter ses explications
merci magali d'être avec nous alors on
entendu tout cela phrase de warda cette
voyante déjà warda al akwa voir dans
cette histoire en fait c'est dan hay
l'autre ouvriront qui lui demander de
faire des travaux pour elle c'est saint
philbert desk winock était alors
absolument elles ont travaillé ensemble
depuis un moment bon awards à dément
avoir si je puis dire oeuvres ayant
aladino puisqu'elle a dit qu'elle
n'avait pas fait ses travaux oui elles
démentent elle dément avoir oeuvré dans
cette affaire la voilà donc elle n'a
rien à voir dans la sphère en fait elle
est là juste prévenu magali bareback qui
est d'avoir des vidéos c'est sa version
absolument elle dit n'avoir rien à faire
alors moi j'étais elle est là mais elle
m'a effectivement prévenu c'est la
vérité est une autorité
oui elle a dit la vérité moi elle m'a
prévenue elle m'a envoyé par
l'intermédiaire d'une personne des
messages et des enregistrements même de
discussions qu'elle a eues avec dana et
qui voulait faire du mal à carla donc
elle a eu cette bienveillance je peux
pas lui ont franchement on peut pas dire
le contraire
maintenant de les envoyer dans une
période où moi j'étais en train de faire
ma grand mère est gravement malade donc
c'est vrai que j'ai pas calculer ce
message et puis j'en reçois énormément
des messages on me dit vos candidats ils
ont fait ça etc etc
et du coup ben je les ai eus on va dire
dix quinze jours après et je l'avais
transmis à kevin à ce moment-là sévit
dans le marais vilain mari de carla donc
là dessus a dit la vérité
effectivement dana et d'après ce que
j'ai compris et tu ne voyais enfin une
fausse voyante qui faisait appel à
howard a pour faire des choses guarda
est une vraie voyante alors alors
d'analystes faire on s'arrête deux
minutes sur dana et parce que dimanche
soir sur snapshot magali vous avait
expliqué ne pas connaître danaïdes oui
et pourtant depuis quelques jours il ya
une ancienne publication danaï qui
ressort sur les réseaux sociaux dans
laquelle on voit quelqu'un qui bourses
ont participé à une soirée d'halloween
chez la voyante mais il ya des gens qui
ont dit que c'était pas vous ouais donc
c'est pas vous absolument pas mais
jamais vu de nom alors je me suis fait
plein de gens qui disent non vous la
connaissiez donc la connaissance donc
c'est alors cette personne ne m'a
contacté deux fois elle m'a contacté une
signe de deuil
dana est une grand en 2019 pour j'ai
retrouvé ça dans mes messages instagram
que je n'ai jamais ouvert donc je les ai
donnés à la prod pour me demander de
faire de la télé réalité
si je pouvais l'intégrer dans une
télé-réalité d'accord
rien de grave là dessus non mais bon ça
prouve qu'elle voulait quand même se
coller au co candidats téléralité vous
devrez donc s'est incrusté dans le
milieu téléréalité et ensuite elle nous
a contacté mon service commercial donc
pas moins directement pour faire de la
promotion via notre agence nous on avait
soumis à la rpp donc l'autorité qui
régule les publicités et la publicité
si on avait demandé est ce qu'on a le
droit d'actionner serait plaint de plein
de gens de chez vous qui avez fait des
placements de produits pour d'année mais
ce n'est pas passé par les agences et ça
je le dis ouvertement il n'y a aucun
candidat c'est parce que nous on avait
refusé le partenariat l'onf et sol et
l'ont pris et j'ai donné là le screen du
message de refus qu'on avait envoyé donc
le service juridique avait refusé j'ai
donné le message et j'ai donné la lettre
de l'erp et qui nous déconseillé de le
faire crise endroit qu'avant votre
agence alors normalement non d'accord
donc voilà certains mais attention sur
le compte de dada et il n'ya que 40 %
qui sont mon âge enfin il y en a 60 %
qui sont d'autres agents dire quand même
et ceux de votre agence vous leur avez
rien dit mais en vrai moi ils me disent
qu'ils n'ont pas été rémunérés qui ont
été invités à cette soirée et sérums et
disney vont payer une consultation à ce
que c'est pas est-ce que c'est pas
est-ce que c'est pas un mais c'est pas
un échange et à leur fait des travaux il
poste un truc alors moi ils me disent
qu'ils ont payé la consultation après je
vais être honnête avec vous je n'en sais
rien maintenant en tout cas tout ce qui
est sûr c'est que ce n'est pas passé par
l' agence est de toute manière quoi
qu'ils ont peu c'est impossible qu'on
puisse dire que c'est passé en deux ans
que ce n'est pas passé par l' agence
gilles verdez magali je trouve que vous
évincer un peu vite les liens possibles
que vous auriez avec dana alors vous
nous dites que deux mais laissez moi je
veux finir quand même la photo elle est
quand même très troublant djeuga sur sur
la photo que considérer la montre et moi
je j'en ai eus on m'a envoyé des
centaines chaque fois j'ai examiné
excusez moi mais sur la photo pour moi
c'est vous oui c'est bien ça alors c'est
votre choisi non mais écoutez je vais
vous répondre à ça à cette soirée là il
y avait si vous regardez d'autres sur
l'instinct g de dana et j'espère qu'elle
ne supprimera pas donc fait vite pour
les screen et il ya la photo de vivian
aussi un candidat téléralité dit je sais
pas non mais c'est pas ça c'est que
comme le soir du 31 octobre parce que
c'est une soirée halloween 2019 donc
c'est cette soirée 70 semaines
regardez mes messages et j'ai pu j'ai
retrouvé et heureusement et je vous les
et screen et est amené j'ai fait la
vidéo pour qu'on voit bien les dates
comme ça on peut pas dire que c'est un
montage
la vidéo divion qui a filmé cette
personne en m'envoyant regarde j'ai
trouvé ton sosie et je vous laisse là si
vous pouvez diffuser moi j'ai répondu tu
alors on a la vidéo regardez combien il
avait répondu de manière officielle de
magali bernard lentéric merad et je suis
choqué par contre il affrontait ce match
apparemment donc c'est ainsi que tu n'as
pas tu n'as pas dessus mais apparemment
ce qu'on va dire donc voilà enfin que ça
va si l'enfant caché c'est vrai qu'à
vous ressemble et c'est oui
après moi je suis pour rien et c'est
vrai que les gens c'est cette photo et
c'est réel c'est réel c'est à dire
qu'heureusement est la chose qui m'a
sauvée parce que regarder comme une une
polémique peut aller vite et regarder
comment on peut accuser quelqu'un très
vite
heureusement vivian m'avait envoyé cette
vidéo est bien ces dates et voyez en eau
bon alors ça doit être ça non mais là on
a bien vu c'est vrai que voilà donc
gilles verdez voilà mes bonnes questions
parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui se
posent la question donc c'est normal d'y
répondre
magali baird a juste ya warda qui vous
accusent d'avoir été à l'origine de ces
vidéos et qui sait vous qu'il y avait
dit on s'en fout on fait fuiter ces
vidéos pourquoi alors je vous explique
c'est pour l'histoire
le samedi on a tous reçu un appel de
marc batta qui a lancé donc les c'est
lucas qui était chez nous ils voient les
matins dès lors il nous a laissé un
petit message vous allez voir voilà m
attaquer un influenceur voilà exactement
château à dubaï et ses salles et à dubaï
le samedi nous a tous contactés les
marseillais kevin mois nous a tous
contactés il nous a dit voilà il va se
passer des choses parce que j'ai des
dossiers
ça va sortir quoiqu'il ça va sortir il
nous a prévenus au préalable le dimanche
moi j'ai pris ma voiture je suis parti
chez carla kevin donc je suis allé voir
kevin pour m'expliquer avec lui pour
l'entente et pour essayer d'être là
enfin avec ce qui est normal j'ai fait
mon travail des agences en fait un de
chalus à côté de lui et on s'est dit une
chose c'est que si ça sort pas de toute
manière comment on peut empêcher que sa
sortie nous l'a dit que ça sortirait
quoi qu'il arrive ça va sortir ils
allaient s'amuser du coup il n'a pas de
ses choix
inzaghi risque non mais je vais sortir
vous aviez ce qui est des sorties toutes
les conversations audio de carla en
train de lancer d
des sorts des choses comme ça il nous a
dit les choses et les a fait écouter aux
marseillais avant que ça sorte
donc c'est vrai que marseille était très
énervé on comprenait pas trop pourquoi
sont là mais parce qu'ils avaient
entendu avant que ça sorte
donc moi la seule chose que j'ai demandé
à marc blata avec kirin parce que
j'étais avec kevin à ce moment là on lui
a dit écoute
ok tu vas sortir quand il a dit on va le
sortir maintenant ce après midi on lui a
demandé s'il te plaît à temps qu'on
mette carla à l'abri avec sa famille qu
elles sont entourées parce qu'elle était
seul au moment où on était avec lui au
téléphone il n'était pas avec nous donc
on a juste demandé kevin et moi à marle
blata d'attendre qu'elle soit auprès de
sa famille pour sortir les doigts et et
le boulevard votre wii et il a fait
voilà donc c'est vrai qu'après il a dit
moi ou kesha temps et vous me dites
quand c'est bon donc c'est vrai qu'on a
dit c'est bon moi quoi qu'il arrive
vous savez quand quelqu'un veut envoyer
une information par exemple il dit une
bêtise excusez moi à public et que
public ne le sent pas ça va sortir sur
closer de toute manière donc en vrai ça
changeait rien pour nous le mal était
déjà fait je sais vous donc donc
attendez coward a dit c'est vous qui
avait demandé de sortir des vidéos vous
avez dit sortez les idéaux dans le
contexte comme ça j'ai dit bah en fait
sans carla était voilà on n'avait pas de
choix
et quand carla était bar accompagné on a
dit ben vas-y ce qu'est ce que tu ton
attention va délivrer car là il faut
savoir aussi que j'ai dit à carla carla
il faut que ça te délivre aussi de tout
ça parce que ça fait des années que ça
dure
et quoiqu'il personne ne te faire du
chantage donc c'est pas grave les sentir
moi tous les candidats de notre agent
qu'on leur dit quand y en a un dossier
quand vous êtes menacés quand dossier
sorte on assumera après on verra près
mais ça sert à le cacher ça sortira donc
de toute manière ça sera malveillants
donc pour la laisser à sortir alors que
justement il a laissé une vidéo regardez
pas ce qu'on lui a demandé
regardez bonsoir cyril bonsoir à tous et
j'espère que vous allez bien
juste pour rectifier deux trois petits
points lorsque j'ai reçu les documents
sur la faire car là il est évident que
ces informations là à les sortir coûte
que coûte
néanmoins par éthique personnelle je me
suis permis de contacter magali et kevin
les principaux concernés ainsi que tous
les candidats des marseillais suite à ça
magali et kevin m'ont appelé pour me
demander si je pouvais reporter la
diffusion de toutes ces informations sur
les réseaux sociaux pour pouvoir bien
évidemment mettre à l'abri
psychologiquement car la la mettre dans
de bonnes conditions lorsque ces
informations là à les sorciers voilà ni
plus ni moins
bonne soirée à tous merci marque en tout
cas merci pour ce témoignage qui
corrobore vos dires williams est la
vraie question c'est qui a fait fuiter
les bruits et pourquoi
car la chancellerie c'est pour dénoncer
les esprits mais je pense alors d'après
ce que j'ai compris
carla a été menacé et elle le dit et
puis de façon il ya des il ya des
preuves aujourd'hui qui sont dans le
dossier elle a été menacée a été
rackettés donc il ya des preuves dans le
dossier de cette personne d'ailleurs il
ya d'autres victimes qui vont pas tarder
à sortir parce que du coup grâce à ça
les gens maintenant se réveille et
accepte et parle donc elle va avoir
d'autres dossiers qui vont sortir
pourquoi on va gagner c'est danahy qui
aurait donné ces années amar blata pour
mettre ses menaces à exécution envers
carla mais c'est votre passion puisque
les notes audio qui peut les avoir à
part d'année mais c'est peut-être fait
sa ba alors qu'à kehl alors bas elle a
dit ici c'est moi qui ai fait les
poupées elle l'a dit elle a dit c'est
moi qui ai failli louper donc les notes
audio qui peut les sortir c'est puisque
c'est la voie de carla donc l'histoire
de carling quelque part elle est je suis
désolé mais elle est elle éclaire donc
servi suivi mais c'est sympa c'est pour
mettre ses menaces à exécution avait
stoppé les paiements quand vous plaît
oui moi qu'il ya une question que je me
pose c'est que pour pouvoir être
sollicités par la voyante et et avoir du
chantage de venant de la voyante faut
bien qu'ils aient une vidéo une première
vidéo de carla
je comprends pas non mais carla n'a
jamais nié qu'elle est allée la voir car
là au moins la merlatière même elle a
demandé
bah voilà ça elle est devenue connue
marche et cetera et cetera
et puis après mais elle s'est laissée
dans un engrenage elle a été manipulée
cas-là menu la démarche béate angèle
même d'aller le dit et on verra suivant
l'enquète mais j'ai pas peur de le dire
parce que je me suis renseigné aussi
comme gilles il ya une vraie équipe
derrière il ya une vraie équipe derrière
cette dalle est donc vous le verrez à la
justice il faut laisser la justice faire
son travail mélanie elle
elle l'a dit et ça c'est vrai c'est vrai
elle l'a dit elle n'était pas seule
c'est la vérité et vous le saurez parce
qu'il ya d'autres victimes qui se sont
réveillées entre temps oui d'agir a dit
magali pourquoi le mari de carla est
partie à dubaï très très vite et
précipitamment
oui kevin alors je vais vous dire il est
parti voir les marseillais kevin j'étais
avec lui - le dimanche
d'ailleurs il nous a fait aussi nous
avons une vidéo où on va on va la voir
la vidéo de kenny vous allez répondre à
cette question c'est vrai qu'il ya plein
de gens qui se posent cette question
pourquoi kévin est allé à dubaï
très vite et bien elle aimait sa femme
alors on va on va en parler un iranien
on passe à la dernière partie de touche
pas à mon poste etc et digne
kevin le fiancé de carla a tenu à sortir
du silence à ce sujet pour rétablir la
vérité regarde pense or tout le monde
soutient m'exprimer rapidement par
rapport à magali berda qui apparemment
ce serait la commanditaire de sortie de
ces vidéos
donc non soit comme ça que ça s'est
passé ce qui s'est passé clairement
c'est très facile c'est que marc batta
nous a appelés à moins d magali comme
jack les vidéos allait sortir ce qui
s'est passé c'est que magali était avec
moi ce jour là carla était chez sa mère
seule et il nous a dit que quoi qu'il
arrive ça va sortir si c'est pas mr à
quelqu'un d'autre c'est tout parce que
le mal était déjà fait j'ai du coup les
vidéos allait sortir
c'est tout ce que viens vous dire je
vous embrasse et là ça bouge pas toutes
les mains de communicateur - rodez 1
j'embrasse kevin aussi la vidéo elle a
été coupée non je trouve que c'est ils
disent tous tous les trois en gros la
même celle qu'on connaît à bing se tient
par la barbichette et on a on a décidé
d'avoir une sorte d'histoire comme ça et
voilà et tout rentre dans le dans le bon
certes mais désolé ne pas répondre aux
fantasmes un peu méchant des gens de
vouloir absolument prouver la méchanceté
de certaines personnes
nous on s'en prend plein la gueule
depuis quinze jours on est fatigué de
cette histoire moi financièrement je
vais vous le dire parce que on m'a dit
mais qu'elle est quel est mon intérêt
aujourd'hui car là aujourd'hui c'est une
de mes plus grosses influences zghal et
mon intérêt aujourd'hui qui se passe à l
poste plus ça fait quinze jours quel
poste plus elle ne peut plus faire ces
postes qui est totalement normal donc en
fait il n'ya pas d'enterrer la seule qui
a un intérêt dans tout ça c'est d'aller
la saint gobain d'intérêt ou arcade
épreuve aujourd'hui à des éléments
galles mais qu'elle a été rackettés
seydoux il ya quand même un qui cale et
la voyante normalement constitué qui
prend 1 million 300 mille ndjeng
quatre ans qui fait ça quand on déjà on
est normal qui fait ça exprès par bolat
a été rémunéré absolument pas car
personne absolument pas mais la personne
ce qu'il ya des gens qui dit oui moi je
vous dis tout ce qui se dit et ce qui se
dit gilles oui parlons argent
moi j'ai deux choses à vous demander
c'est de la rumeur peut-être je me fais
l'avocat du diable
avez vous oui ou non le soir vous savez
que marc batta va sortir les vidéos vous
l'a appelé pour lui demander de différer
lui avez vous proposer une somme
d'argent pour qu'ils ne le fassent pas
absolument pas n'y a pas une proposition
de votre pas sous cette forme la marque
la taille les influenceurs il fait des
postes et moi j'ai tout qui peut être
vérifiée jamais on a versé de l'argent
malgré la tasse en avoir un truc en face
un poste ferrer un salaire de piano
basse verizon de ce fait et ça se
vérifie exactement il n'y a jamais eu
une très longue et moi j'ai une grosse
société
j'ai des commissaires aux comptes tout
est contrôlé tout est carré on peut pas
s'amuser à faire n'importe quoi
deuxième chose deuxième chose est ce que
au moment où kevin est allé à dubaï pour
compléter la question de gérard dine al
til proposer un mode jeu kevin ben oui
outre haïti at il pu at il proposé une
somme d'argent à marcq blata je vais
vous donner la somme comme à citéa les
gigantesques qui lui aurait proposé pour
qu'ils arrêtent de publier une somme de
plus de cinq cent mille euros
est ce que vous avez eu devant moi cette
information vraiment c'est le nom
hébraïque du fantasme
je me devais d'y poser la question mais
vous pouvez mais moi je suis venu je
réponds en toute transparence
j'amène des éléments après je vous dis
la vérité celui qu'il veut et croit
rêver du roi je n'ai pas à me justifier
mon travail je le fais correctement moi
mais mes candidats je les encadre
j'essaie de les aider et être là pour
eux et ils le savent après les fantasmes
des uns et des autres c'est plus mon
problème vous démentez bien sûr bernard
montée justement magali puisque tu dis
que tu encadre des influenceurs et
notamment carla comment se fait-il que
des départs est au courant de cette
histoire qui date qui j'allais si
longtemps et les dieux gellée dit
bernard la dernière fois que je suis
venu c'est pourquoi j'ai dû moi j'étais
au courant uniquement du racket c'est à
dire je savais qu'à la saisir a quitté
sa mère me l'avait dit et c'est moi même
qui envoyait carla chez un avocat avec
kevin j'ai prévenu kevin c'est moi qui
l'ait dit à kevin voilà que tout le
monde le sache c'est moi qui ai dit à
quel jeu joue maintenant maintenant
pardon ya un moment donné ou moi j'avais
pas connaissance de deux de ses six gros
déjà et j'avais pas je pouvais pas
deviner que c'était à ce point là et que
c'était avec des menaces avec des notes
audio
moi j'ai entendu les notes audio sur les
réseaux sociaux comme tout le monde tire
pour moi c'est chez moi aussi j'ai eu
des doutes tout le monde a eu des doutes
même carla a eu des doutes tout le monde
et même carla abandonné ses 10 mai est
ce que va cesser c'est aberrant c'est
aberrant et l'histoire bao plus j'avance
et au plus j'ai des éléments qui me font
dire que oui carla elle a été rackettés
et en plus de ça quand je vois que dana
et et bah quand je regarde maman elle
m'a contacté dd oui des candidats télé
réalité partout moi je suis je consulte
pas les brillantes ya aucune une
vaillante qui peut dire je vais
consulter le consulat de paris donc je
suis pas dans ce milieu là et après on
peut me reprocher ok mais je sais
excusez moi je ne suis pas dans son
compte bancaire comme j'ai dit allons
avoir un castrat lui il a largement fait
pour bien qu'on comprenne
donc pourquoi est ce que marc batta lui
sans les vidéos quel est son intérêt
mais c'est leur travail comme des
journées longues santé visite guidée en
conflent elle pas en années ce malgré sa
longueur c'est un journalise et mayence
1-0 bas aujourd'hui c'est un nouveau
métier
il ya plein il n'est pas le seul dans le
data c'est pour ça qu'on savait et il
nous l'a dit mme façon je vous laisse
pas le choix je le sortirai ce sens
voilà oui mais peut-être mais non après
ça génère des folies du projet qui
semblait dans une mégane et mégane 2
la crédibilité balgobin produit par
nicole notât
comment moi je suis pas stressé dans le
domaine mais comment vous expliquez que
c'est à durer autant de temps et ce ne
soit pas sorti avant puisque je crois
que les parents ont porté plainte n'ont
rien on est là départ ils sont allés
effectivement chez sa mère pour faire
des menaces au pouvoir même agressé ça
c'était quoi ya un an et demi à trois
ans à l'e3 sa mère a déposé plainte
moi j'ai été mise au courant à peu près
ya un an que y'avait du racket d'accord
je savais pas que ça venait de ce milieu
là je n'ai sa mère m'a pas voilà bon
après c'est comme ça j'ai su ce que
j'avais à savoir et je lui ai dit à
kevin maintenant commencer c'est je
pense qu'aujourd'hui faire ça escroquer
les gens les manipuler c'est un vrai
métier
c'est malheureusement fossé des
procédures il ya trois ans mais parce
qu'il la tenait et justement comme par
hasard là ça s'est arrêté parce que moi
l'ayant dit à kevin kevin a mis le nez
dans les comptes etc
et après à tous et tout csu et puis ça
commence à éclater karl allard était bas
bim bam boum
trois mois après comme el hadi ould ali
el hadi quad à nice sur ce plateau
qu'elle avait vu carla en janvier baby
boom janvier février mars trois mois
ferme l'album babou trois mois elle sort
scellé le site de questions précises
est-ce que margot la taille dans votre
agence
alors non marquent la taille les
indépendants dont il n'y a aucun contrat
d'exclusivité aucune agence gens qui
bossent jamais avec vous s'il a deux
arrivées le faire faire des posts
d'accord se passe avec vous comme
d'autres agences et ensuite est-ce que
vous me confirmer que carey de sortir
une marque de cosmétiques oui ou non une
marque de cosmétiques est-ce que c'était
dans ses projets professionnels
j'en ai pas connaissent d'accord ok
d'accord oui pourquoi donc pour
synthétiser parce qu'on aurait dit
qu'elle avait ce projet là et que ça
aurait fait des tensions dans votre
agence vis-à-vis de nabila alors à james
que maeva guillaume à sa propre marque
de cosmétiques naji a aussi annoncé
l'acquisition pour résumer régaler pour
synthétiser pour vous donner c'est une
imposture et qui escroquent non pas que
carla mais tous les candidats de télé
réalité c'est ça moi je pense qu'elle a
mis le grappin sur des candidates et les
rats microbes leur attention
et je pense que c'est une
professionnelle et/ou et de toute
manière on le saura avec l'anc est
maintenant je pense qu'il faut que tout
le monde puisse avancer et dans le temps
la justice fera son travail ramènera des
éléments et puis c'est tout je dire
qu'est-ce qu'on n'est pas en vrai tout
ce tous autant que nous sommes nous ne
sommes pas on sait qu'on peut pas savoir
c'est à dire c'est on verra avec le
temps mais apparemment ça sent très
mauvais pour pour dana et puisqu'il ya
des victimes qui se je pense que gilles
est au courant il ya des victimes qui se
sont réveillés la nuit au coton la lutte
ça ici c'est vrai qu'on est là on l'a on
la croyait sur parole c'est fou il a eu
l'agression qui structurent et moi
j'aurais revenir à ce que beaucoup de
gens me demandent et c'est votre
attitude le soir vous car est quasiment
vous acquiescez pour que la vidéo soit
publiée en demandant quelques heures de
répit
vous saviez qu'il y avait un racket
publié une vidéo alors qu'il ya déjà eu
des plaintes avant que vous savez qui à
raquettes à ce camp mais laissez moi on
savait pas que ces liens a laissé moins
et mieux encore sarah vous venez nous
dire que vous saviez avant laissez moi
finir ça s'appelle du recel publié une
vidéo comme ça pourquoi vous n'avez pas
à ce moment là tout de suite avec carla
et kevin était à la police en disant il
faut interdire ces publications
excusez moi je trouve qu un peu
facilement quand même et beaucoup de
gens le pensent un peu facilement
finalement vous avez cédé à la
publication de ces vidéos
et ça ça paraît bizarre ici cl
aujourd'hui vous vous êtes journaliste
d'accord quand vous avez une information
qui va sorte je comprends pas en fait
comment vous pouvez dire à l'agent que
c'est le journaliste c'est la personne
qui va sortir nous nous a dit mot pour
mot sa va sortir je le sortirai
quoiqu'il - la seule à qui je pense dans
cet état c'est carla le reste je m'en
tape ça va sortir
et puis vous voulez je vous dise ça l'a
libéré la petite ya un moment donné faut
arrêter c'est tout faut arrêter le
carnage si ça sort ça sort et elbeuf
battre et elle va progrès le prix quand
même acabit et quand même alors
continuer comme ça pendant des années
payer les gens pour ça sans rire c'est
ça la solution beaucoup de gens du lit
dans la télé réalité mais pis mais non
payer des gens pour ça je ne suis pas
pour il s'appelait donc vous inscrire
mais il ya beaucoup de raquette 3 dans
la télé c'est ce qu'à dieu on a on à 37
on en direct il ya eu énormément de
cambriolages sur les rhumes la
téléralité on en voit plein qui partent
à dubaï il ya plein en plus en plus de
gens qui disent ni parts à dubaï pour
être en sécurité parce que il y avait
énormément de raquette autour d'eux et
bien sûr il ya des gens mal intentionnés
que chez huawei
il faut le dire que ces réalités sont
partis à dubaï à cause de ça oui oui oui
mais ce qui est intéressant
ratchet et pensez vous portez plainte ça
c'est un vrai vous savez la dernière qui
a été agressée à marseille c'est maeva
gainey elle a eu un couteau sous la
gorge quand même et sa fuite et de la
police donc à une enquête de la police
des polices parce que l'information a
fuité de la police elle même
donc en fait on vit dans un monde qui
est un peu spéciale aussi et après on
dit non non mais non mais ils gagnent
beaucoup d'argent mais ok très parce qu
on a vu la vidéo mais n'en a pas on en a
rigolé tout à l'heure de sarah fresu
voilà qui est notre danseuse inquiet pas
chez vous d'ailleurs non non voilà et
qui disait c'est à cause d'eux quand on
diffuse deux cantons début de nos
salaires après on se fait racketter
on se fait agresser je pense que
effectivement il ya des sommes dues ont
été dites qui sont qui sont explosives
et forcément ça appelle des personnages
on a donné des sommes ici progression
d'oralair données magali c'est vrai que
c'est à va 2 je sais pas moi de 200 que
ceux de 50000 euros par mois à 300 400
mille euros oui je vous comprends que
dans la poésie je pense qu'on n'aurait
pas ces chiffres maintenant après les
candidats montrent aussi sur les réseaux
sociaux saab s'est trompé dans les sens
pour pas accabler non plus que la presse
et les candidats se montrent aussi un
certain niveau de vie sur les réseaux
sociaux donc ils ont peur ils ont plan
les candidats il s'était il était à
dubaï gestion compliquée ici en france
oui vraiment oui donc c'est pour ça que
je vous mentirais si je sais que c'est
enfin c'est politiquement pas correct de
le dire mais il faut être honnête oui et
c'est la vérité ils ont peur moi même
j'ai pas mal f1 c est donc cette
histoire de voyance est ce que c'est
voilà ça fait partie de deux d'une
pratique de raquette
moi je pense que oui pensez quoi ouais
je pense que oui oui des options
montagne pas une vraie d'après ce que
j'ai compris aussi de de l'association
parce qu'il ya une personne qui
s'exprime et d'ailleurs pour vous dans
l'émission là il ya quelques jours qui
fait partie d'une association
apparemment elle est très très elle est
vraiment mal vu et elle est connue des
services de police elle est connue dans
cette association pour être une personne
très très mauvaises qui suppose web
et donc en fait marc batta qui est donc
le blogueur qui a sorti cette
information il s'est fait manipuler
est-ce que lui pensait sortir à scandale
sur carla et au final c'est juste des
menaces qui ont été mises à exécution
ses seins 800 les informations qu'ils
reçoivent et quand il est sur qu est ce
qu il pense sortir y pense sortir un
dossier sur carla oui c'est que ces
moyens que lui de ne pas sortir un
dossier de rachat de huy à shawi est à
dire de dire que carla voulait du mal à
fait laminer marseillais voilà donc la
voyante il aurait manipulé marque c'est
ça en lui disant j'ai des preuves que
carla a recours à la série alors qu'en
fait c'étaient des fausses preuves riz
et de magali cancan danahy dit vous
allez voir il ya des trucs qui vont
arriver au dessus oui c'est quoi elle
parle de quoi mais je sais pas savait
pas de quoi le combattant vous j'attends
maintenant il faut attendre et dana et
je ne la co n'est pas c'est à dire qu'on
peut me montrer ce qu'on veut on peut me
dire ce soir et vous l'avez menacés sur
les réseaux j'ai dit à danané oui c'est
vrai je les menaces et sur les réseaux
parce que j'étais en colère et parce que
j'ai dit je ne nommerai pas la croiser
dans la rue parce que pour moi c'est moi
je pense moi j'ai trois filles d'accord
et si ça arrive à une de mes filles je
vous le dis c'est pas cette personne si
elle fait sa une de mes enfants
oui je suis désolé je la défends ce
pardon du ferme mais c'est pas bien
pardon à tout le monde vous verrez ben
ouais mais faut pas il faut pas me dire
oui mais attend pourtant mené à un peu
de la parole ça fait pas de mal c'est
long mais voilà je désire y avait
défoncé les gens puis on en a ras le bol
parce que nous ça fait quinze jours
entre franchement c'est quoi cette
journée c'est pas qu'ils livraient qui
disent voilà pour l'instant lorsque je
vous dis à une enquête de police qui a
encouragé toute manière on aura
simplement faim et simard glatin reçoit
d'autres vidéos qu'est ce qui a été
convenu en fait il vous prévient tout de
suite il est montre il démonte pas alors
il n'y a rien qui a été convenu d'accord
après près de dix heures
ok oui je voulais revenir sur
l'information que vous avez un sens
développé que que magali a confirmé sur
le le racket qui concerne plusieurs
candidats de télé réalité et qui
notamment à marseille et est pratiquée
par une bande est peut-être une autre
bande et les policiers vont tenter de
savoir s'il y a des liens avec des
cambriolages ou des raquettes qui aurait
pu être pratiqué à l'encontre de joueurs
de football de l'olympique de marseille
quand savait qu on a parlé de ça c'était
pas que l'école est alors ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il ya des joueurs de marseille
comme dans d'autres clubs 1 qui ont été
cambriolés victime de racket
y at il un lien entre ces bandes il faut
savoir que ce sont des célébrités très
exposé il ya des pratiques qui ressemble
un peu donc ce sera un des éléments de
l'enquète voilà satini un mois ce que je
ne comprends pas c'est pourquoi en fait
lorsque vous avez reçu les informations
du coup de marque blatter pourquoi ne
pas tout simplement je pense pour
essayer d'atténuer du coup ce buzz
explosifs laissés faire car là une vidéo
pour justement prévenir qu'ils allaient
avoir des infos qui allait sortir etc
je pense que ça aurait peut-être été une
solution pour que le vote soit un
minimum atténuer nos partenaires sociaux
car la possible comment comment tu veux
qu'eux car la pression snap et 10
rebonds les amis je vous préviens les
des vidéos de moi qui vont sortir mais
c'est impossible
chaque match je pense que ça aura lieu
les 10 et après je pense que dans ce
moment là on était dans un moment sous
tension bien sûr on était en panique
on n'était pas bien on était avec plein
de questions je suis honnête je préfère
dire la vérité je vous ai tous moins de
questions on était tous très stressée et
on a réagi tous comme des êtres humains
avec peut-être des choses avec des
erreurs peut-être pas des erreurs je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que on a fait du mieux qu'on
pouvait un beau essayer de pas protéger
tout le monde dans ce malheur et dense
est parce que il ya aussi les autres
marseillais qui sont victimes qui sont
des victimes collatérales de tout ça
donc ça n'a pas été une montre facile et
est-ce que vous pensez que carla va
retourner du coup dans le milieu de la
télé après tout ça vous gêne absolument
aucune idée
la cascade ah oui ce que je voulais dire
magali c'est que on vit tous une période
très difficile et tout cet étalage que
font tous ces influenceurs on le
comprend ils sont jeunes ils sont
heureux ils sont beaux et ils montrent
les derniers sacs et dernières voitures
des maisons sublime et c'est ça aiguise
l'appétit de gens malveillants
forcément donc ma oui mais c'est très
mais ça ne les entend pas leur reprocher
mais je dis simplement que ça aiguise
l'appétit des gens justification mais ça
leur met ses problèmes c'est que j'ai
voulu dire un truc annoncé l étalage
comme ça c'est terrible
oui mais c'est le sait aussi être
influent sur le dessus et se montrer tel
que l'on est c'est mon essai montrer
notre vie sur les réseaux sociaux
donc s'il montre quelque chose qui n'est
pas leur vie bah c'est hypocrite c'est
pas vrai c'est pas de ce ne sont pas des
vrais influenceurs donc peut-être que ça
plaît ou ça plaît pas mais ils montrent
ce qu'ils sont réellement
merci en tout cas magali est ce que vous
pouvez nous résumer donc pour vous
l'histoire votre version en quelques
secondes
je pense effectivement que carla a connu
cette voyante à 17 ans elle a consulté
et puis ça a dégénéré
ils ont compris que c'était un gros
poisson et puis après c'est parti en
live totale et c'est parti en raquettes
menaces etc et aujourd'hui on en est là
il ya eu du chantage et bat la fère est
sorti et c'est malheureux mais comme l'a
dit carla chez vous sur ce plateau elle
l'a dit elle même
ça m'a libéré travers ce qu'elle a dit
merci en tout cas on va voir ce que vous
avez lancé un sondage oui 82% beghdad et
oui il ya 82 %
donc c'est 100% merci en tout cas très
bons sondages